[Musique]
de la grenadine ça me rappelle toute mon
enfance parce que c'est gentil nous
saluons 10 à une grenadine pour la
petite et si sage c'est moi
nadine va servir pour cuire les zestes
d'orange pour moi j'ai un petit passé
c'était une attention si gentil je ne la
trouve alors donc aujourd'hui comme à
part la grenadine qu'est-ce qu'on parle
d'un dîner on va faire un cervelas show
truffé au oui mais vous savez pour bien
cuire un cervelas il faut légèrement le
piquer avec une petite aiguille et de
faire partir à l'eau froide c'est à dire
que pour cuire un saucisson même si
sochaux il faut jamais les métallos
brillant on les fait partir à l'eau
froide doucement et que l'on frémit et
en général au bout de 20 minutes un
cervelas est cuit et le pit combien de
fois aux bains trois ou quatre fois pour
pas qu'il éclate c'est à dire pour faire
partir l'air bon et vous le quiz est
toujours à l'eau frémissante c'est à
dire que juste quand ça va bouillir et
on arrête mais on la minute et après
vous le laisser dans l'eau dans l'eau
bouillante et là il fait ni de cuir vous
laissez pocher après doucement et on
couvre non il vaut mieux que ce soit
découvert pour vous voyez bien l'eau qui
frémissent et bien sait jamais si ça
bouge ça vous parle et après des tirs
n'a pas le simple là on va faire une
voyance ou pierre une vaillance ou
pierre c'est une volaille qui twitte à
l'étude à les
a étouffés dans une soupière il soutient
qu'il va dans le four qui va dans le
four et il va être bourré de légumes
c'est à dire on va mettre à peu près
tous les légumes qu'on peut trouver il
ya du maïs
des haricots verts
et jolie haricots verts c'est un blanc
de poireau quelques oignons
n'avait à peu des navets blanc ou de
nouvelles noires des pois gourmands le
pois gourmands c'est un légume
merveilleux et vous savez qu'un pois
gourmands sauter comme ça carrément ce
juste au bord c'est à dire ou alors
blanchi et cuit comme un rique au vert
c'est merveilleux c'est à dire bien
souvent le pois gourmands on le fait
avec du lard ou le fait avec des oignons
mais votre poids gourmand vous faites
bouillir de l'eau et vous le cuse et
comme un légume faire et à ce moment là
vous retrouvez un pois gourmands
pouvaient faire différemment c'est à
dire vous le faites sauter au beurre
simplement et c'est merveilleux c'est à
dire sans gras du tout c'est plus en
plus
carottes oui petit pois et bien sûr une
volaille du sel du poivre
il n'y a pas de haricots verts bon mais
il ya pour les haricots verts ci a pas
de progrès il ya pas de place l idéal de
mettre la variété un légume est
retrouvée bien mais derrière ça on va
faire une sainte d'orange et rien
d'autre si on va mettre un vrai talent
parce que les vacherins son merveilleux
et les vaches alors préciser parce qu'il
ya toute une histoire déjà
plusieurs vacherin mais les vacherins du
jura que je pense c'est quand même ce
qu'ils sont les meilleurs et vous avez
la meilleure façon de manger un vacherin
c'est de laisser dans sa boîte et de le
prendre à la cuillère quand il est bien
bien mûres bien fait alors vous le
cacher qu'il ya comme le chevalier dans
de la crème et si vous le servez avec un
peu de pain grillé de campagne c'est
merveilleux et puis la dernière affaire
le range donc le range c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué parce qu il faut
faire les zestes d'orange et vous savez
que pour faire un access d'orange il
faut couper d'une certaine façon conte
écolo êtes sans avoir trop de plumes
blanches
ah oui à 16 noeuds très très peu et perd
les ai filé dans les fractures anodine
et après je vous ferai colonnes avec un
économe tenir avec un couteau un couteau
a épluché qui épluche très très très fin
et après je vais voir comment on coupe
les oranje parce que c'est une façon de
couper leur antre une salle de rangement
pour moi c'est désagréable quand on
trouve des pots quand on trouve des
pépins oui une salle d'orange il faut
que ça soit très nette bien sûr c'est
long mais c'est très agréable je pense
que l'on va essayer de passer au travail
j'ai oublié on doit oublier l'ex allié
on va boire un vin des corbières parce
que ce sont des vins très bon ces dames
1 oui je crois qu'il faut un
décor bien on va vous savez il ya des
vins de toutes catégories dans toute
région et vous savez j'ai oublié cette
voie là une fois qu'elle est mis là
dedans on va là encourir un feuilletage
donc j'ai trouvé un peu de feuilleton on
peut trouver les feuilletage tout près
on n'est pas obligé de faire deux
feuilletons sur la balance si on n'a pas
de feuilletage on peut même mettre une
pâte brisée savez une pâte brisée c'est
facile tard patata non sucré non sucré
et ça vous servira donc à la pour but
cette pâte de couvrir votre soupe hier
et de cuire à l'étouffée dedans c'est là
ce bien d'un pad couverte que vous
n'avez pas de
le couvercle est remplacé
je pense qu'on va commencer la recette
et on va commencer par la volaille parce
que la volaille c'est ce qui a plus long
à cuire et cette volaille on va la
mettre voilà vous refaire voir là bien
découpé la volaille oui je vous faire
voir pour nettoyer une volaille parce
que bien souvent une volaille c'est il
faut bien nettoyer une volaille alors la
voyez vous couper juste à la jointure
c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait pas de
petites hausses qui rien du tout beau
coupé à la jointure ici la pâte c'est à
dire il n'ya pas des caïds aux cantons
coupe qui est souvent avec le couteau il
reste une et khalid aux abords vous
savez jamais des pâtes dont se sert pas
des patchs parce que les packs vous
savez il faudrait les blanchir c'est à
dire pour avoir l'eau bouillante les
tremper dans l'eau bouillante et les
éplucher parce que voyez autrement ça
sent le barreau et ça donne un mauvais
goût non là on va nettoyer la volaille
on va la faire le plus simplement
possible cette volaille puisque
finalement on va laisser tous
là on va découper voyez la découpe et
l'arrière pour que bien et vous faites
vous l'ouvrez pas trop vous allez voir
c'est très très facile tiens vous
devriez quand même éplucher
les oignons et puis moi j'ai plus choix
les navets
bolive la nettoyez vous enlevez le jab
beau c'est à dire où il ya les graines
il faut bien détaché le jabot
ici et là vous râlez le long des côtes
pour enlever les poumons
ont bien enlevé les poumons de la
volaille et on va retrouver le soir le
coeur vous vous en servez du foie dit
que oui on peut conserver observer le
foyer et à l'utilité si un jour on fait
une terrine faire une terrine et et
garder le foie ont fait une terrine
merveilleuse le fond de volaille est une
chose même cela plusieurs fois on peut
les faire sauter dans la salade les vins
d'autres fois on peut non mais là dans
votre place ou pierre à votre poulet en
soupière oui eh bien non vous voilà oui
là je coupe même pour les ailerons ges
la volaille assez
le plutôt si mais je la brique pas et là
je vois que jenny veulent être même dire
toujours de la truffe toujours delattre
non mais c'est pas obligatoire si vous
voulez ça l'humour et pour parfumer un
peu et surtout pour la décorer si on a
une truffe on m'avait appris à glisser
la toile entre la poule donc de détacher
bien hélas si vous voulez on va mettre
quatre petites lamelles de truffe mais
très petit mais s'il ya par la truck
aucune importance on n'en met pas parce
que c'est pas utile
voilà mais ça fait bien puis sa part
fume comme un sa part su s'envoyer nous
glisser
une larme sur la donc lavé la une sur le
blanc de la volaille
il avait ici
là une autre sur la cuisse nous fait
attention quand vous faites ça ne pas
déchirer la volaille là pour la pole
plus délicat et l'autre mais tu es ici
donc voyez vous avez donc la volaille
sur les quatre membres qui est truffé
voilà alors donc vous à répondre là ça
c'est fini on est le jeu légumes
et on veut mettre la volaille dans la
soupière
mais avant de mettre la volaille de la
soupière on va mettre à peu près
50 g de beurre
60 g de beurre là au fond au fond de la
salle et demi sel j'aime beaucoup le
beurre salé les voiliers à l'intérieur
de bougival ipoker soir salle et je mets
une petite pincée de sel gros mais à
l'intérieur de la volaille donc le sel
va fondre doucement et va vous savez la
volaille par l'intérieur alors du sel
nom que lui seul bien sûr du poids après
alors je mets le maïs
c'est pour 6 personnes à peu près oui
ces personnes les petits pois
voilà et maintenant on va couper donc
tous ces légumes mon petit poisson cru
ils ont cru tout écru ou écru et là
maintenant on va attaquer nos alors ça
c'est plus est les navettes vers vous et
moi je vais peut-être éplucher une
carotte avec l'économe
20 jamais l'économie
jamais un col à cette importante de
navets à une peau très épaisse à ces
peluches toujours avec un couteau bon
alors vous épluchez assez épais assez
bien parce que la poule dans cette année
les lieux
et moi je m'en vais pêcher la carotte
peut s'est plus fait plus hachée avec
avec ecône en cours doit être très très
chaud le four doit être à 200 degrés et
la volaille va cuire 1h presque deux
heures parce que vous savez c'est long
du cycle à chaleur pénètre à l'intérieur
a pris la soupière fait alors les
carottes
envoyer si finalement c'est une c'est
une jardinière de légumes qui va cuire à
l'étouffée avec la volaille qui va cuire
avec tous les légumes et on met pas
d'eau c'est à dire que tous les légumes
vont rentrer de l'eau suffisamment pour
cuire par eux-mêmes
minutes de préparation
vous savez il faut quand même que chez
légumes pour quand même hein la voilà
les navets
donc peut-être mettre encore un navet
parce que tout ça ça peut être faire un
peu avant mais je crois que vous voyez
c'est pas la peine de se soit coupé
régulièrement un dans un ménage on n'est
pas là calibré savoir si le morceau le
plus grand au plus petit clip au moment
où on va les laisser entier mais on va
coupler les génériques aux
banquiers gras bien avoir quelques
programmes en entier devant mais
quelques-uns on va tous se retrouver ça
après alain
quelques haricots verts va mettre des
aléas cover j'ai envie de les couper
tiens ta place en qui ils ont eu juste
blanchi un petit peu parce que même
quand même temps c'est à dire ils ont
été passées à l'eau bouillante
voilà ça qu'est-ce que j'en fais ça on
va mettre le blanc de poireau on va
remettre un petit morceau de d'un qu'on
va couper d'un
voilà
ici
on va mettre un blanc de poireau un des
morceaux les piles oignons
connaissez la formule pour couper un
poireau en julienne donc d'employer vous
avez un petit tonneau là où le coupé à
moitié seulement oui donc à ce moment là
vous allez avoir donc un plat et quand
vous coupez ici dans une julienne de
poireaux
donc pourquoi son côté 1 julienne
vous avez compris oui mais c'est très
difficile bravo le poireau beau coupé
admis oui demi vous êtes vous et allez
donc ça vous fait des couches composé de
feuilles et après vous pouvez transférer
en julienne facilement
j'ai compris
et la julienne de poireaux savez ça peut
servir à beaucoup de choses bon alors
finalement non
voilà les oignons
les oignons va remettre encore un petit
peu maïs dessus trouve ça très joli un
petit peu de petits pois
voilà et maintenant on va débarrasser là
pour étendre le feuilletage et le mettre
sur le sur la soupière
il faut d'abord une volaille in voilà
que vous vie des époux salé à
l'intérieur avec du sel gros avantage de
cyrus gros c'est que le seul gros font
doucement et parfume bout de volaille
après vous êtes tous vos légumes on
avait dit le maïs les haricots verts les
petits pois les navets les petits
oignons les carottes les pois gourmands
et un petit peu de poireaux et un petit
peu de poireaux
alors le feuilletage
voilà et vous savez que le poivre du
moulin vous connaissez c'est ce qu'on
préfère oui
voilà
alors vous en rendez vous sur d'autres
rouleaux la feuilletage
vous savez un feuilletage c'est une des
trempes il faut un kilo de farine
il faut 600 g de beurre ont fait une des
30 avec l'eau c'est à dire on mélange la
farine et l'eau
et après on fait important mais ça c'est
assez difficile et je pense qu'un jour
on pourra peut-être faire un feuilletage
oui parce que finalement
tout les ménages et a maintenant ou un
frigo avant c'était très difficile de
faire du feuilletage parce que c'était
une question de froid mais maintenant
tous les ménages ont
un frigo et on peut très bien faire le
feuilletage et je crois que si on leur
fait voir vous allez bien alors leur
expliquer
parce que on peut pas si vous voulez en
pâtisserie on peut pas improviser il
faut 500 il faut 1 5 g de beurre ni rien
à faire on va faire un rond point on va
faire un rond si on a trop on coupera un
peu
voilà
donc vous avez le rendre voltage qu'elle
a nous recoupera plus on va donc casser
un oeuf pour faire un jeu de dorures me
connaissez oui
l'a19 entier et on va bien le taper avec
le pinceau pour pouvoir coller sur
voilà et donc on badigeonne l'intérieur
voiliers du feuilletage
voilà
là on n'a rien oublié c'était sale et
c'était pas vrai parce
qu'une fois que le couvercle dessus
c'est fini
voilà vous savez vous découper pour que
ce soit et le feuilletage qui reste peut
nous servir un peu le tas de choses et
alors là il faut pas mettre au fond tout
de suite parce que si vous mettez au
four tout de suite le feuilletage appris
du coeur et finalement il restera pas
sur votre soupe hier oui
eh bien vous laisser reposer une demi
heure un endroit frais a donc il faut
prévoir
parce que si on met au fond tout de
suite il va se produire un phénomène
tout le feuilletage va se rétracter et
il y aura plus rien c'est à dire que le
la pâte et élastique rihanna vous
connais bien sûr le tour
vous voyez votre volaille et en fermer
hermétiquement
à l'intérieur
vous avez
fait pas une invention française les
anglais il ya longtemps qu'ils vont tous
leurs chicken pie et toulouse avec le
feuilletage dessous vous mais je pense
que c'est une très bonne sur des bases
alors là vous voyez vous dorer un pur
doré ou jaune comme ça ça a pour but de
faire bien doré la pâte quand elle va
cuire au four à vous c'est parce qu'on
va faire on va nettoyer on va poser
notre soupe hier la délicatement et puis
on amène à poser on va la faire reposer
et on la mettra au four dans un moment
de les couper ses oranges mois je m'en
vais attaquer
et bien attaquer pour les couper
je regarde un peu comment vous faites ça
hein
mettre au four est assez chaud posée
alors voilà l'autre volaille et là le
fou et à 200° 1 et je m'en vais la
mettre dans le four 1 chauffée à 200°
moitié sol moitié voûte
voilà et dans deux heures au nouveau on
nous est
admirablement bien cuites bon alors
maintenant on va faire nos orange un jeu
vous faire voir pour couper les oranje a
pour couper et orange
c'est très facile il faut prendre les
oranges et faire des petites nos pieds
hélas après vous couper
comme ça
non mais je pense que tout le moment je
veux faire celle ci je vous fais avec
nous en fait voir une complète un oui
c'est facile voyez ya plus un bon impôt
blanche et on va voir des oranges
admirablement bien éplucher et après je
vous fais à voir comment on va faire les
aces pour les cuire
dans la grenadine voyez vous faites
chaque tranche il ya plus un grain de
peau bien sûr c'est un travail de
patience mais vraiment là on and that
d'orange comme on doit avoir une salle
d'orange
voyez tous les âges
sont enlevés
on écoute et on va commencer les est ce
parce que la presse ne pourra pas tout
faire
voilà c'est de commencer les est
alors je vous faire voir comment on va
faire les est là pour faire les essais
pour les cuirs vous allez vers les est
on va tous les maîtres comme ça
et là on va les et ciselez le plus
favorisé sakho 6 oui enfin ça sur
l'autre mais on est 6 est le plus fin
possible mais c'est à dire quand ils ont
tous 6 les traits fins
et voilà ce qui reste tout l'intérieur
de leur range avec les peaux blanches
avec les petits filets à huy
formidable vraiment enfin le vrai
continent
vais laisser un peu de blain et faux pas
qui est blanc du tout hein enfin ça va
alors maintenant on va cuire l'inceste
conclure izeste vous mettez les aces
dans une petite casserole
vous mettez d'issue crois qu'il ya de
sucre et alors vous allez voir on va les
cuire dans cette fameuse qu'on abîme
c'est à dire que la grenadine à magda
linette un sirop parfumé merveilleux et
on va les cuire dans la grenadine on va
les faire confire dans la grenadine à
peu près pendant une demi-heure et en
même temps ça va nous sucrer nous orange
sens du tout oui voilà dit une grenadine
et csu et zeiss et là on va mettre ça
sur le feu voilà et ça prend une demi
heure à peu près oui mais on va quand
même ajouté une petite goutte d'eau et
dire une passe et une toute petite
goutte d'eau calais voilà combattre bien
voilà
et là on va faire que les satisfaits
[Musique]
elle est formidable
attention c'est il faut faire attention
les porcelaines c'est très très chaud
ces traits des gros gants
vous avez pas les gros bras voilà le
plat voyez
envoyez votre la fuite l'état
l'intérieur alors comme vous arrivez sur
table pour découper le feuilletage
vous allez sentir ce parfum drôle mais
là tu fait
alors voyez
la volaille et 8 avec tous les légumes
tous les légumes se sont réduits
veuillez on retrouve nos pros gourmand
on retrouve et on retrouve notre
volaille qui a été cuite absolument sans
os sans rien du tout et voyez toute
l'eau
jr dont il faut bien mélanger là on va
trouver une quoi louche
voilà ça y est
et on va mettre alors donc vous mettez
vos légumes autour et vous avez tous
légumes qui sont autour
il s'agit bien vous savez avec le jus ou
savais tout aurait on retrouve le
poireau on retrouve les pois gourmands
on retrouve toutefois
en creuse est bon et les légumes sont
aussi latruwe alors le plus difficile
c'est de trouver le salage exane a parce
que ça c'est très important mais je
pense que pour une soupire comme ça si
on veut en mettant 15 g de sel oui et
bien c'est tout ce qu'il ya de fait tout
ce qui est correct
quinze grammes de saint
louis et nos attentions
bull et voilà la volaille 1 boule de
câbles
ça va être plus tôt
valoriser ce qu'ils sont cuits
les s enfuit dont vous voyez vous avez
vos est qu'ils sont là et
donc les années légumes et son le poulet
le
voyez donc vous avez les
alors donc vous laissez refroidir vos
est ce parce que si vous mettez des est
chaud sur les oranje ça va pas aller
mais enfin pour faire voir après comment
c'est fini voilà ce que ça donne
donc vous avez des skis sont colorés
parleur est ce que vous voulez que je
vous fasse voir comment qu'on découvre
une volaille pour que puisse finalement
je sais pas si les ménagères savent bien
décuplée voilà il faut une fourchette et
même si vous avec un couteau de table on
est alors c'est le même principe vous
marquez ou marquer bien votre volaille
et vous détacher d'abord la cuisse au
loyer doit être cuite regard et c'est
bien cuite
nation voilà donc vous avez la cuisse
voilà d'abord ma cuisse
après pour détacher votre
l1 d'accord oui
elle avec la truffe voilà qui est juste
sous la peau
donc vous voyez vous avez votre moral de
volaille qui est détaché de la carcasse
jusqu'à présent moi j'ai tout bon
après on va pouvoir tisser très bien
donc voudrait
même temps mes légumes
alors après vous faites mais trouver un
plat trop petit en fait un plat plus
grands
l'autre puis votre cuisse
bien l'autre l autre l
d'après
vous détacher bien pautrel c'est à dire
que il faut bien la marque elel comme
vous vous rendez vous découpez la la
jointure
que ça fasse pas de la jarrie c'est plus
pratique oui alors la voûte et
achèteront des tâches et bien sûr les os
oui
alors là vous avez une volaille qui
étaient cuites avec ses légumes dans la
cuisson je pense que comme tout sera
prêt quand vous aimez bien là oui
comment vous faites là ici non mais ça
vous le voulez moi j'aime bien ça manger
ou de manger vous le voulez mais oui
vous le coupez plus ça prend bien sûr
qu'on peut le coupé par c'est ce que je
vous demande vous détacher leblanc stade
et vous comment il ya les eaux cela vous
détacher leblanc khin win voilà en
principe voilà à vous détacher le blanc
c'est facile
voilà c'est très très beau me dis jamais
non jamais je recherchais à la cuisine
des moulins et puis là vous mettez tout
légume après autour et donc vous avez
une la volaille qui fait aux légumes
les poids comment vous appelez ça vont
pouvoir des pois gourmands des pois
gourmands alors voilà les poids lourds
la volaille ces légumes sont couvertes
de feuilletage les oranje à l' orange et
maintenant vache elle ne peut ni corbier
et sans oublier le serbe l'a truffé
merci pays ont aplati ah oui
[Musique]